collègues merci madame la présidente
merci pour ces deux heures là des
changes très riche très clair je
remercie vraiment de tous les
interlocuteurs pour la qualité de la
présentation et dans laquelle évidemment
nous sommes beaucoup retrouver alors
pardon d'être peut-être des trolls ont
donc je vais essayer de
d'être clair en tout cas je pas vraiment
de questions mais des interventions sont
des sujets qui font partie de mon
exercice quotidien donc évidemment de
trois points je voudrais évoquer
première chose évidemment
on connaît les deux problèmes on a deux
problèmes d'abord on a un manque de
moyens et il faudrait très vite
éclaircira lorsque ce white par la loi
peut-être le qui fait quoi
on a un problème de moyens on le sait on
a un problème de moyens humains on a un
problème de manque de professionnels de
santé on en connaît bien les les
les causes on écrase en diminue même le
numerus clausus les numerus clausus dans
les années 90 alors que dans cette même
période
la france va passer de 54 millions
d'habitants à 67 millions d'habitants
avec évidemment un quatrième âge qui
s'est développé un quatrième agent
milieu rural qui s'est énormément
développée qui vit plus longtemps et qui
évidemment est très exigeant en demande
de deux besoins de santé c'est une des
difficultés des médecins généralistes en
milieu rural d' sur le plan chronophage
donc à un manque de professionnels de
santé ça chacun a fait le constat
à moment donné
comment prendrons les décisions
politiques qui font que on va amender
retrouver le nombre de moon provincial
de santé suffisant le présent de la
république a effectivement fait
supprimer le numerus clausus à la fin du
concours de première année de médecine
c'est une bonne chose on imaginer le
nombre de d'étudiants en médecine motivé
qu'on a sacrifié le numerus clausus
entre 1981 et et 2017
mais il n'ya pas que les étudiants en
médecine qu'il faut évidemment
pensée est fléché je pense aux aux
étudiants en kinésithérapie insuffisant
insuffisant
et donc quand est ce qu'on décide d'en
bouger les les quota insuffisant aussi
le nombre d'orthophonistes est
aujourd'hui la réponse en orthophoniste
et la première réponse urgente après un
avc et donc il faut là encore ce
s'interroger sur quel est le plan en
france pour que d'ici 2030 nous ayons
assez de professionnels de santé partout
moi je vous rejoins évidemment tout de
suite parce qu'il faut le dire un moment
donné notre de dot matinée je rejoins
bien évidemment le professeur nisand sur
le on va pas imposer
je crois que le pas de contraintes
d'installation
c'est évident
ça m'est arrivé plusieurs fois de
prendre l'exemple vous ne pouvez pas
dire un jeune médecin d'aller
s'installer à romorantin dans l'entente
de temps si on n'a pas envie il ne fera
pas son exercice professionnel aussi
sympathique soit la sologne de la façon
la plus adaptée possible par contre que
à un moment donné on plafonne des
installations et c'est le cas des
pharmacies depuis de la loi de 1941 qu
on plafonne des installations par
département si c'est le niveau de
pertinence
je crois que ça peut être un des sujets
de réflexion que l'on que l'on peut
avoir sur le nombre de professionnels de
santé qu'il faut par territoire à voir
je vous rappelle aussi quand même parce
qu'on a parlé des hôpitaux des centres
hospitaliers ça vaudrait le coup
d'ailleurs d'en faire l'évaluation à un
moment donné dans la loi hôpital
patients santé territoires d'août 2009
si je me souviens bien importé par mon
excellente consoeur roselyne bachelot il
y a décrit qu'elle une garantie d'avoir
un centre hospitalier à moins d'une
heure de tout habitant dans ce pays bien
qu'on puisse d'ailleurs le le vérifier
alors manque de moyens humains c'est
certain manque de moyens financiers
oui c'est là que ça fait le lien avec le
qui fait quoi parce que par exemple le
beaucoup d'initiatives de bus et moi je
salue ces initiatives qui ont parfois
été portés par des collectivités
parce qu'on sait très bien que les
agences régionales de santé maintenant
ne mette plus de moyens il n'y a plus de
consultation itinérante par exemple en
matière psy
parce que les ars ont coupé les vivres à
un moment donné mais le qui fait quoi
vous savez que en france la compétence
santé n'est pas distribuée on a un code
de santé publique
heureusement on est une autorité de
santé publique les ars sans doute
beaucoup à dire sur les ars mais le
contrôle en l'exemple que je connais le
mieux
une inspection de la pharmacie et ne
peut dépendre que d'une arf ça ne va pas
dépendre d'une collectivité parce qu'on
en a parlé beaucoup de transferts dares
éventuellement vers les conseils
régionaux il ya quand même une autorité
de santé publique qui doit rester un
moment donné m de l'organisation de
santé en france mais le qui fait quoi et
malheureusement pas défini en matière de
santé est donc temps que ça sera pas
défini c'est qui paye quoi toujours la
même question alors les communautés de
communes auprès d'initiative sur des
maisons de santé pluridisciplinaires les
départements pris des initiatives tant
mieux mais par exemple pour avoir porté
dans le département dont j'étais le
président encore il ya quelques semaines
un bus de consultation
bucco dentaire c'est le coup et 100000
euros rien que dans le fonctionnement
parce que il faut effectivement à
praticiens ça c'est certain du matériel
ça c'est certain mais il faut aussi un
chauffeur pour l'entretenir et donc
c'est le problème de de la mobilité du
milieu rural c'est comment on amène
l'offre de santé l'accès aux soins
ça s'adresse ce sont nos priorités c'est
teddy par quasiment tous les
intervenants l'offre de santé les accès
aux soins partout
alors on a des choses qui fonctionnent
on a un maillage qui fonctionne et donc
c'est peut-être là dessus qu'il ya un
certain nombre de choses pour lequel on
peut s'appuyer les pmi les pmi alors ça
on sait que l'épée me relève des
conseils départementaux
moi je crois beaucoup au réseau des
sages-femmes et maïeuticien alors je
rajoute et maillots titia ce que nous
sommes l'indignation égalité hommes
femmes la présidente et il y a
maintenant des hommes qui pratiquent
et donc faciles l'ordre a changé sa
définitis et sa définition est mort de
sa femme
mais il ya aussi des hommes qui
pratiquent et donc moi je crois qu'il
faut qu'on développe ce réseau de
sages-femmes et maïeuticien en libéral
parce que c'est une vraie chance
or on en voit peu sur le territoire et
on en fait je pense pas suffisamment la
promotion on a un outil qui est très
fort tout cas là encore pardon de
prendre l'exemple que je connaisse mais
quand je préside le département de la
vienne en ce qui concerne des collèges
nous avions mis des infirmières partout
dans les collèges nous avons affaire à
la tranche en ce 15 ans et évidemment
c'est une tranche particulière notamment
chez les collégiennes et là il faut
donner à dans les collèges partout sur
le territoire en hyper ruralité en
montagne parce qu'il ya des collèges par
tous les moyens d'avoir des portes
d'accès aux questions de santé et je
pense que dans les collèges des
infirmières il ya une confiance et une
proximité et une liberté de parole
là ça on a une vraie chance lui
pardon d'insister sur les pharmacies
sujet ou où je travaille toujours
depuis une trentaine d'années en milieu
rural mais on a un maillage des
pharmacies par la loi de 2,41
alors juste pour la petite histoire vous
savez qu'il n'y a que deux lois de il
n'y a que deux lois de l'état français
vichyste que nous condamner donc tous
évidemment qui ont été maintenus c'est
celle qui permet les licences iv dans
les bistrots et celle des licences de
pharmacies
ça n'a aucun lien à part que nous
vendons de l'alcool dans les deux cas
mais cette loi-là a permis de maintenir
un réseau de d'officine partout même si
aujourd'hui des tentations d'écraser des
licences et là je crois qu'il faut
s'était d'ailleurs notre collègue marie
pier richer de deux l'un est intervenu
hier en question d'actualité
vous savez que quand une officine est
dépourvu de deux pharmaciens et bien
elle est automatiquement fermés et au
bout de 72 heures est salissant s'est
écrasé aujourd'hui et ça c'est un vrai
drame pour les territoires ruraux
parce qu'ils perdent sans doute le
dernier pont de santé qui existe
et là encore dans les propositions nous
ferons parce que c'est un outil utile à
la salle outil utile pardon à la santé
des femmes ne jamais écraser une licence
de pharmacie toujours essayer de trouver
il faut que les pharmacies et les moyens
d'être les acteurs de santé que autre
que dans la dispensation de médicaments
alors là encore c'est évoquer une pièce
de confidentialité une pièce technique
c'est essentiel vaccination les capable
de tout faire un jour propos quand on se
limite aujourd'hui un vaccin grippe
vacciner évidemment a sujets sur
lesquels
un pharmacien va pouvoir sans problème
démultipliez un certain nombre d'actes
pour apporter des réponses de santé
voilà les quelques sujets il ya la
question de la téléconsultation qui est
un vrai sujet moi je suis pas un
défenseur des télécabines parce que il
faut en main donné qui est l'humain dans
dans un échange de de souffrance ou de
problèmes de santé parce que des fois
évidemment la discussion mais la
téléconsultation et qui est
pharmacien peut être formé une sage
femme peut être formé à metz 1 1
un lecteur d'échographes avec derrière à
distance grâce au numérique un
spécialiste de l'échographie qui peut
guider et qui peut apporter une réponse
voilà quelques quelques pistes mais il
faut se poser la question évidemment des
moyens et du qui fait quoi pour apporter
des réponses
pardon d'avoir été très long voilà un
président merci chers collègues
rapporteur